hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on absolute and
relative quantitation for targeted
metabolomics and lipidomics by dr
sheahair mozin
i am abby of lavroots and i will be
moderating today's event
before we begin i would like to
encourage you to engage with us you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time during the presentation
simply type your question into the ask a
question box on the left side and click
send
we'll answer as many questions we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right or use the
ask a question box on the left
it is my honor now to please welcome dr
shaher mozin
hi everyone the title of my presentation
is
absolute quantitation of fragile
metabolites and semi-quantitation of
lipids
here is the agenda
i'm going to talk about absolute
quantitation of some fragile analytes
using a very well established
dmrm targeted metabolomics method
followed by semi-quantitation of lipids
and then we will talk about the path
from discovery to doing semi-quant of
lipids
followed by conclusions
before i begin i want to talk a little
bit about the instrument that was used
for these analyses
it is the 6495c
it has been redesigned
and there's there's a lot of front-end
design changes
as well as the rough pump that is being
used now it is a single pump and it's a
higher capacity pump
and then also there is incorporation of
the vacuum shield which is really useful
when we have to pull out the capillary
and we don't have to break vacuum then
to pull out the cavalry because of this
vacuum shield
so sort of the two palms that we had
before them as 40 pumps it's been
replaced by one
ms-120 pump
and it's it's higher capacity pumping
decreased concerns for vacuum
maintenance
and because of this higher pumping
capacity
we have improved performance of the
ifunnel as well
high funnel design is also changed so
this is the previous design and this is
the new version
and uh before we would have a big
pressure differential between funnel one
and from final two centaur going to
tutor and that caused a lot of
a lot of turbulence in this region
and now you can see that we begin with a
pressure of a much lower pressure of two
torr
and there is not a very big pressure
differential and as a result of this the
mean free path of ions
has also increased and so they don't
encounter a lot of collisions when they
are entering the ion funnel region
this is about the agilent jet stream
source and the hexapore capillary there
is thermal focusing that produces very
efficient heating and desolvation of the
droplets
and then we also have the hexabor
capillary which has six inlets
for greater sampling of the ion cloud
this results in more ions entering the
ion funnel than
is possible with a single bore capillary
all of these enhancements lead to better
sensitivity and better stability for
fragile
analytes
so this is the method that we have used
to look at fragile analytes for the
first part of this presentation which is
doing targeted metabolomics with fragile
analytes and doing absolute quantitation
of these fragile metabolites the method
that i'm showing you here on the slide
it's it's very well established it's a
published method it uses iron pair
reagents which is the 10 millimolar
tributal amine that you see here
methanol water gradient
and
the method number is shown in the next
slide right here
it comes with a method setup guide and
then there is a database of mrm
transitions that you can download
depending on how many analytes we want
to analyze
it's uh it's a method for 219 central
carbon metabolites just want to point
out that the method was originally
developed by dr adam rose brock of
stoney brook school of medicine
conditions for the source are shown here
it was established the method was
established for the 6470 triple quad
and as we are using the 6495c we have to
figure out
what the
high pressure and the low pressure ion
funnel settings rf voltages should be
and these are the values that we achieve
for these fragile analytes
list of fragile analytes
that we have chosen is shown on this
slide we reached out to the thought
leaders in metabolomics
and they all indicated that these are
analytes that are very fragile they fall
apart very easily very challenging to
analyze these and achieve the low
detection levels
so we chose the set of analytes
and
what i'm going to show you is doing
absolute quantitation which is the goal
of metabolomics the goal of metabolomics
is
figuring out what the absolute
concentrations
of analytes of these metabolites is and
so we use that targeted dynamic mrm
method that i was showing you in the
previous slides and what we did is
incorporate isotope dilution mass
spectrometry to do this absolute
quantitation
the
the isotope dilution mass spectrometry
the advantage is that it gets rid of
ionization suppression effects as well
as any bias you you may have from sample
preparation
or instrument
conditions
and
the only downside of using isotope
dilution mass spectrometry is the cost
of
purchasing
in this case since we are looking at 219
metabolites which is what this method is
set up for
imagine buying 219
um standards to do isotope dilution mass
spectrometry
to circumvent the cost of purchasing all
of these standards we have used
c13
incorporated east from cambridge isotope
lab
and what they do is they grow the cells
in a c13 and rush medium and the
resulting
metabolites in the extracts have more
than 99
isotope enrichment so
all the metabolites in the c30 enable
east is incorporated with c13 which is
like more than 98
so using this approach we have reduced
variability it improves pressure
precision and accuracy
increased level of confidence in a
reported metabolite because you not only
see
retention time of the c12 analyte which
would be in the sample but also the c13
that is spiked in there the retention
times and responses would match
it's easier for method development and
using the c13 incorporated is it is it
becomes very cost effective
so with this approach what you do is you
add
the same quantity and volume
of c
13 to the standards and the samples so
you keep that's the same
and then we can use the ratio of c 12 to
c 13 to create a calibration curves and
ultimately come up with an absolute
value
for metabolites
so it is like an elegant way of elegant
way of doing it and we don't really have
to know how much of c13 is present for
each of these metabolites
because we are using ratios
method is described in this paper here
and i have to thank michaela for sending
me this article
and
this article is for doing
amino acids and we have used it for
looking at metabolites
these are the results
and i'm showing you the results first
for the phosphoenol pyruvate which is
one of the challenging fragile
analytes that we talked about i want to
point out that all of the study was done
with
matrix in the samples so this is these
are not pure standards that we are
showing responses for these are
standards that are spiked into a matrix
and the concentration of matrix is
something like a hundred million
extract of e cells which comes out to be
about 0.75 milligrams per mil
so each of these panels that i'm showing
you here it's it's going to show the c12
response
and then the c13 that is spiked in
and we are using the ratio of the c12
c13 to create our calibration curves and
then what's shown on the right side is a
1000 dilution of unlabeled east and this
is something that is naturally present
in the east and we are looking at the uh
at quantitating this as well
based on the calibration curve that we
generate with a c12 to c13 ratio
and so we are looking at
the phosphoenol pyruvic acid transition
167 going to 79 and we can see that
retention times are right on between the
c12 and c13 for kind of like a full
confirmation
and then
what's shown over here is the area
counts at
1.23 femtomole per microliter is the
standard concentration
we inject two microliters so that comes
out to be about
0.46 femtomoles on column
and this is the signal to noise that we
can achieve with that level at that
level which is a signal to noise of um
of 12.
also i want to show you that um you can
you can see that the response of see the
thing that is spiked in
the standard in the sample
uh it's uh
about the same counts 59 000 like 60 000
counts
so
we wanted to see if we could go
lower than that this is phosphoenol
pyruvate
246 atoms on column
in matrix and you can see that
with this it's a it's a very small peak
the account of about 2800 but again a
signal to noise ratio is something like
67 68
and the corresponding c13 internal
standard that is spiked in and again it
is in matrix of 100 million
cells
this is the calibration curve
and we
are going from
femtomoles
to 24.6
animals
and you can see this this is like eight
levels so there is
um
seven orders of magnitude
because each of these levels is a one to
ten dilution so if when you see eight
levels there is like seven
um seven orders of magnitude for the
quantitation going all the way from
femtomoles to nanomole amounts on column
and you can see the linearity it's shown
here it's a 99 r square value of 0.997
uh which is really amazing and then the
points over here that are the lower
concentration
are shown over here they are zoomed in
so we can see it's linear down to like
the lowest point in the curve
lactate one of the other challenging
molecules
it's um 22 femtomoles on column is the
response that is shown here
and then this is in east 2.4 femtomoles
on column
and again this is all done in matrix
which is 100 million
cells
lactate 1.78 femtomoles on column
and this is the this is in matrix with
the c12 and the c13 lactic acid same
retention time
and lactate curve
we can go from something like 178
animals on column
to 17.8 nanomoles on column nine points
so this is eight orders of magnitude and
you can notice what the r square value
is it's like 0.999
all the way down to the lowest points
it's linear
and again lactate we're showing you here
it is in matrix
100 million counts of these cells
atp
i'm also showing the blank over here so
you can see this is the bank and we
don't really see anything
and then this is atp at 50.8
atomos on column
it's a very small peak
1350 counts but again if you're looking
at signal-to-noise ratio
it's 72.5
and
so we have
atp 50.8 atomos on column
in the presence of a matrix
and now this is atp with its c
13 internal standard same retention time
and then this is that lower level we can
achieve which is 50.8 animals
and you can see the area count and the
signal to noise
curve for atp is shown here seven orders
of magnitude
n matrix
and this is eight levels so that's seven
orders of magnitude all the way from
uh
animals to nanimals on column
now
i said well what if i add one more point
how is the r squared value going to
change so we had an r squared for eight
levels of 0.99
and now we are going all the way
uh increasing that to nine levels
animals to animals on column
and this is eight
orders of magnitude nine levels
and you can see when we expand these
points at the low concentrations it is
linear down to the lowest point
which is just amazing and again i want
to mention that we are using ratios of
the response
and not using the absolute areas
that has uh gives us that advantage of
increasing the orders of magnitude and
linearity that we can achieve for
doing
absolute quantitation of these analytes
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate again it's
something that's very challenging
and we can just showing you that
this is six point five nine femtomoles
to six point five nine animals on column
six orders of magnitude here
and then the points over here are
expanded here
concentration of matrix again it is um
the 100 million cells this is
oxaloacetate
and we have
five levels here
0.98 leucine which is again one of the
very challenging molecules and you can
see that it falls apart very easily and
what's shown over here is the lowest
level we can achieve it's which is 1.53
femtomoles on column
and then it shows the linearity over
here
blank and then leucine at 1.53
femtomoles on column
citrate seven orders of magnitude
this is eight levels that are shown over
here
and um same thing
situated at 1.04 femtomoles on column
with that c 13 internal standard
shown here
and that's the end this is the last
slide for
looking at doing absolute quantitation
with fragile analytes
and
we are using isotope dilution mass
spectrometry and the c13 that we are
using to spike into the standards and
the samples
the c13 incorporated east from cambridge
isotope labs
by doing that we can get
more orders of magnitude linearity for
each of these species
and we know that the newly designed
6495c ion funnels work
because they
we have this amazing sensitivity down to
atom levels for very fragile analytes
and so that's improved our
limit of detection and limit of
quantitation
for these fragile analytes
okay so we are going to shift gears here
and talk about doing targeted lipidomics
on the 6495c
so
until now i have been doing untargeted
lipidomics with hqtof
and with untargeted epidemics we get to
see everything that's in the sample
we know that lipids are very diverse
very diverse molecules and um
we have diver diversity within lipid
classes we can imagine for example
here's the r1 and the r2 are two the
acell chains
if they
we can have different lengths of these
chains we can have different positions
of these double bonds
there is stereoisomerism around these
chiral centers
and then there is the head group itself
that could be different
with all of these we can imagine having
many many many many
theoretical number of molecular lipids
very
so many
lipids in the sample that it would be
almost impossible to look at each one of
them
and make sure that whether they are
there or not in the sample
so how do we go about doing targeted
epidemics
when there is so many different
possibilities of molecular species
in a lipidomic sample
it's almo it almost seems like a like an
impossible task
and when we are doing targeted epidemics
on a triple quad
it's almost like having a tunnel vision
when because we only see what we set up
the instrument to see we don't see
everything
so how do we go about it
so
the rest of the talk is about doing
targeted epidemics
what we did was start with a very well
established method
for looking at 660 unique lipids
in a sample
this method has been published and i'm
showing you the article over here on the
left side
and you can take a look at the article
it uses a eclipse a c18 column
and
the gradient is with water acn and ipa
using ammonium formate
as the buffer
and
as i mentioned transitions are for 660
unique lipids
and what i would like to show is that we
can use this as a starting point
add to this method depending on what we
are looking at what kind of sample we
are dealing with
when we do when we look for
when we look to do the targeted
epidomics we need to have some idea of
what we are after
and then make sure that we are
incorporating
lipids that have to do with
our sample
what we want to achieve from
analyzing that particular sample
so i want to show you the the workflow
of doing targeted lipidomics
using a method such as this and then
building on that method by adding more
lipids to it and also we want to make
sure because when we go to a triple quad
the goal again is to do quantitation
but because there are so many so much
diversity of lipids
we can do class based
semi-quantitation
so that's the goal that i want to take
you through now
so using
the method that i showed you
what what i did
was spiked in lipid standards these are
40 standards that i'm showing you on the
slide
concentration of these standards is
shown here pico moles on column
and um
we have about 40 standards that are
spiked into the east
so east is my favorite sample it is from
the previous metabolomics experiment we
don't expect to see that many lipids in
the east but they're there
and it's a methanol extract that they do
so we do see some lipids and we have
added in the 40 standards
and we want to take a look at
we want to set up the method to do the
660
unique lipid transitions it's a dmr
method
see what we can see so this is mrm
transitions for the 40 standards that
are spiked into the yeast extract
and so we are going to see these
standards as well as what is in the
sample as well which is the lipids that
are shown in the baseline here there are
lots and lots of them
and we can take a look at it and they
are all responding so this is targeted
so we have
um we have response for each of these
transitions
here's a workflow
so this is informatics annotation and
semi quant
so we start with the dmrm data file that
we get from
doing these experiments
and we can put it through
mass hunter quantitative analysis
program
and
i'll show you the template in a minute
we set up to do
class-based quantitation
of lipids
and then we get an amount of each lipid
which is going to be
amount that is kind of like a
class-based
amount
we can take the data files
to mass under qualitative analysis
and
algorithm find by mrm will extract out
all the different mrm transitions the
chromatograms from those transitions
integrate the peaks
and then
put
all of those annotated features in a
chef file the chef file has annotated
features
and area counts for each of these
features
and we can take that to mpp for
statistical analysis
which is a program mass profile of
professional if you want to look at full
changes we are not really interested in
amounts of each lipid we are more kind
of like comparing samples looking at
full changes
we can take a look at the lipid matrix
feature plot
clustering there is volcano plot all of
those statistical analysis tools are
available in mpp
and all of these we can we can make use
of
looking at targeted
with the targeted dmrm data files
so this is the template from mass enter
quant
and so it's brought in a whole i'm just
giving an example of pcs these are a
whole bunch of pcs
that are in the sample
and what is shown on the right side here
is that we have to create compound
groups
so this 13c 130pc
is something that i spiked into my
sample
at different levels to create a
calibration curve
and the response factors from this
calibration curve is getting used
for all of these pieces
they actually have pcs with different
carbon chain lens spiked into the sample
so depending on how many carbons i want
to choose
if something has for example
um r1 and r2 that are like 24 22 carbons
i can select
a
response from a standard i spiked in
which is which has higher carbon
chain
highland carbon chain
so this is how you would set up to do
semi quant by specifying which
calibration curve you want to use
for
lipid class
so this will make more sense now so this
is 13 opc and you can see that this is
my calibration curve
i'm using this calibration curve to
quantitate
pcs in the sample so this pc is pc 16
120 or 24
double bonds on this um
r2 chain and you can see that these are
the amounts that it found out if it's
flags at blue that means it's below
um the lowest point in my curve here
and um i might have to like increase it
by one more point
to rebuild my calibration curve to
quantitate this and
so this is relative class based
concentrations and the values that are
shown here is in pico moles on column
something that is flagged red because
it's a huge amount
highest amount that i have is 1.5 pico
moles and this is 85 pico mole so this
is way this is like another seven counts
of this one
um see species
so this is results are for pc 16 1 24
and east
based on response factor 4
at 13 0 pc
so we can do that figure out the
concentration of different species not
just pcs but lpcs c e p
p s p i whichever whatever we want
and using
the same class
standard at different levels to build
calibration curves and use responses
from that
to figure out what the amount of
how much
what the concentration of these
different species are
in our sample
with mpp that's the other path here
is using find by mrm and using mass in
the qualitative analysis
here when we want to use mpp we are not
really interested in a semi-quant value
for the lipids
we want to look at four changes we are
more interested in looking at doing
relative quant
what is the difference in the lipid
species between two samples or two or
more samples doing differential analysis
figuring out which lipids are different
and then figuring out full changes
and with these tools we can
look at kendrick mass defect plots we
can look at
feature plots of different pet classes
versus retention time there's a lot of
things we can do with with mpp
uh for lipidomic samples
so for doing this part of the workflow
and making sure that it all works
it's um i made up two samples
two spikes and the second spike
was twice the concentration of the first
one so it's level one and level two
level two is
doubly concentrated as you can see in
these um this picture here there are two
superimposed one on top of the other
excuse me we have
um the first one which is half the
concentration of the second one second
one is double
so you can see so this is what we want
to put into mpp make sure it's working
so this is clustering this is east
when it says 222 this is double the
amount and you can see you know that's
more red blue is like lower amount red
is
higher
up regulated and down regulated so you
can see
that we have lots of reds here
and also we can take a look at heat map
and in the heat map notice how something
that is one one one versus two two two
these are all reds
so they are all regulated and then
there's a really nice um color scheme
here it shows different kinds of lipids
that we are looking at
and
how they are
more in
the spike that is twice the
concentration
so this is just proving
that
everything all the tools are working for
us in this targeted workflow
and what i'm showing you here again is
the full change which is amazing that
even though we are just doing relative
quant
one versus the other it shows up right
value which is like a twice twice the
amount that i spiked in
here's another view which is the matrix
plot of the lipids
and we are looking at the lipid class
which is 170 iso pc 17 lpg 17 opc
you can see that the ones that are twice
the amount are all
flagged red
these are all red versus the blue here
which is the lower value then
so we went through
doing targeted lipidomics
but
what if we wanted to add more lipids to
this essay
what if we
didn't know what was in our sample
and
we
set up the qtof in the more discovery
workflow
and then we wanted to add those lipids
that we found in the discovery mode on
the qtof we wanted to add it now to the
triple quad
to do semi-quantitation
or do relative quantitation with mpp
look at four changes and so on so there
are like so many different ways we can
think about this that the triple quad is
really
to
measure lipid species with greater
accuracy and precision
but again it is things that we set up
that we know
we want to look at
but the unknowns in the sample if we
didn't know what was in our sample
and we wanted to
validate
what we are already looking at in the
triple quad or revalidate or add more
lipids then we have to go from discovery
q
annotation on the on the triple quad so
this is the workflow
if we wanted to do discovery
and then set it up to do some iquant
this would be the workflow for that
so we run our samples on the q-top
and because it's a q-top we are looking
at everything in the sample
and it may not be the best
limit of detection that we can get with
a more targeted approach on a triple
quad
this will give us an idea of what is in
the sample what kind of lipid species
are there in our sample
and then from here we go to the lipid
annotator that's going to annotate the
lipids
it makes lipid ids based on msms level
information
and
then we can take that information
go to the lipid creator
and
make our list of transitions using the
lipid creator go to skyline feed in the
data from the q-top in the skyline and
see which
mrm
transitions our heads
for
our
data file for our sample
and then that information can be
imported
into
triple quad
as a list of mrm retention time
information comes from skyline because
we have fed in the
data if we keep the same chromatography
between the qtop and the triple quad
then we are ready to go
this is going from discovery all the way
to
doing
targeted epidemic then
this part of the workflow we already
talked about once we have that
information the annotated entities we
can take it either to mpp
do the statistical analysis
or we can take it to mass and the quant
to do
um
the semi-quan
so that's the workflow if you wanted to
go from discovery to doing
semi-quant on a triple quad
so here's the lipid annotator and we
have annotated the lipids
and then we can take a look so for
example
there is bmp that was found in the
sample with a q-top
and then we know
the essay that i showed you before did
not have any bmps so our goal here is to
add bmps to our list of lipids
so we go to the lipid creator
and this is a really great tool if
somebody hasn't used it
we have the option of choosing the acyl
fatty acid chain lens
and when we give it this information how
many double bonds we're looking at
and it creates the list of transitions
for us which is this example here
and then we can take it
to skyline those transitions can be
exported to skyline we feed in the data
file to the skyline skyline and we can
see that the ones that circles
the ones that are actually in the sample
these transitions can be exported out
into mass hunter
acquisition
and then we are ready to go
so those transitions can be exported out
and then we produce the data here the
dmrm data files
then get annotated and they go into mpp
or
mass and the quant
so
that is the workflow for doing targeted
epidemics from discovery to semi quant
with that
i am ending my talk
just as a summary the new 6495c
is has better sensitivity
and it's better for fragile analytes
because the newly designed iron funnels
do a good job with these fragile
analytes
we have taken a look at some of these
fragile analytes and we show
the absolute quantitation results using
stable isotope dilution mass
spectrometry
we show six or greater orders of
magnitude linear dynamic range for
quantitation
for fragile metabolites
we also show the workflow for doing
targeted
lipid assay
with statistical analysis tools and
semi-quantitation
tools
using mass hunter quant
thank you for your attention
for that wonderful and very informative
presentation
we
now will begin our
question and answer
portion of the presentation and we
already have a couple of great questions
in the panel
um
as a reminder
questions we can just submit to the ask
a question box to submit your questions
the first question i have for you dr
shahar is can you recommend a sim a
sample preparation method for the love
level
analytes
yeah
hi everyone
so
we have published methods for
extracting metabolites and removing
lipids from the metabolites
to give us
very good response for
for any kind of provides whether they
are they are levial or they are very
stable so just look up
and
they should be
extraction methods
that are automated extraction methods
for doing metabolomics
so if you just google
agilent metabolomics workflow you should
see extraction procedures
as well as manual as well as
the more automated procedures that don't
not only do the extraction but remove
the lipids from the sample as well
great thank you so much and it looks
like uh john has a comment um
sure so actually just to add on to
shahir's comment we actually have an
automated robotics device it's the bravo
metabolomics solution
and we're going to use these uh emr
plates that are capable of actually
performing an extraction we can pull the
lipids out away from the metabolites and
then have a really nice quenched
metabolite sample
and this is working quite well
especially in terms of trying to provide
some type of a standardized automated
workflow
in the lab and it doesn't require people
to learn programming don't have to have
automation experience it's a very nice
device so that's something we'd be happy
to follow up on if people have questions
wonderful thank you so much john and
shane dr sheaher
it looks like that concludes our
questions for today if there are no more
questions
um
this presentation um
is uh just as a reminder it will be
posted online
and we'll be addressed to the the email
address you provided the time of
registration
i just want to thank all the
participants today for
listening in and thank you again dr
sheahair
for your wonderful research and
presentation and to everyone who
participated
we in and we hope you enjoy the rest of
the event
thank you
thank you
you